I think most of you have already started
on the graphene I haven't spent all that
much time to mentor because you guys
know how to do the basic ones you know
what they look like we did that like
right at the beginning because you're
doing normal trig functions right but
they can be changed in a few different
ways and they're always in you're
familiar with already so that's why I
haven't devoted all that much time to it
I think map on your own Steve you've
been on work out what they look like but
I just want to go through it
methodically so that you are though
there's a couple of tips and tricks to
help you do this well and then I think
that's basically it like there's nothing
else on the industry
you guys have covered at all which gives
us some time to revise your class papers
well yeah so the big topics for
integration and inverse tree including
old you know a special retrieve stuff
from before words they're a younger
generation and so on there is quite a
geometric research actually the first
topic which I kind of skipped over
because I thought you guys could do that
kind of on your own in this revision
time rather than me wasting time the
beginning of the term sort of teaching
you stuff with your reader okay so then
we'll come into court in geometry so we
didn't I didn't devote any time to it
even though it's there in the program
because I think you guys I mean that you
learnt it like you and a half ago so
yeah I think you've got the krugen have
a flip to and that's what these next
couple weeks are for yet
no I would say it would be equal parts
trig and integration of this they're
both huge topics there's lots of
different kinds of questions that come
up a lot under integration right we
should do definite integrals with
definite ones we can do Simpsons and
trapezoidal and volumes and so on okay I
could basically guarantee if you
remember from the end of your ten you
know when you did your topic tests on
those four topics right and they were
kind of different to an exam because it
can exam you like I'll study these kinds
of things and then you'll get a question
on this one at this one in this one
because we can't possibly buy at any
time which literally tests everything
but a topic test is okay look look at
all of these skills we're going to test
all of them we give you you know you got
a graph you've got to do the area of a
shape you've got there and so on right
integration is gonna be like that in
this exam okay because every aspect of
integration there are no kind of weird
Sider science sort of not very common
pieces every part of integration is done
with a lot let's now if you remember
transformations means you know you take
something which you know and then you
just cinch it a little bit right so you
have a kind of modified version yeah
there are three main kinds of
transformations that we're going to
cover under any mystery function and you
know all of them already
okay so the first one the easiest one is
when you change the scale on the ground
okay see either you stretch it or you
compress it or something like that okay
so how would you do that well but it
look like if you change the scale of say
sine inverse
yeah that's right well actually all of
these are going to be the placing of
constants in places the question is what
places are grow so example okay we did
this you know we looked at that and the
integral but that turns into that right
so if a is a constant like say - okay
this is going to be a horizontal change
in the scale and obviously if I changed
you know fine if I put a three there
that would also change better to be
vertical okay so there's this scale
changes and you can also change the
position or shift the ground elsewhere
okay so how might we do that if we
wanted to shift it horizontally say want
you to how would we do that
just from regular sine inverse yeah good
so X minus one
if you've ever since it's backwards
right so this is going to go to the
right one beat it you know by extension
if I wrote you know we tend to see it
over here for instance actually probably
be the angle okay that would have the
effect of pushing it up player two units
radians I'm gonna suggest that it's
going to be more helpful to us to
actually write it like that but we'll
get to examples in a second okay but
that's doing the same thing it's the
same sign of s crap but now I'm pretty
into its form that is 1 plus you made
how the kind of transformation that uh
that comes up with me I suppose you know
if you think about these
this this is kind of this is a phase
right where you think about original
tree graphs this is phase this is both
period and epochs you depending on
whether you change Y or X what's there
yeah good so because we can reflect
write or flip the graph okay so how
would you if I wanted to take study bus
and turn it back to front that way left
to right how do I change that how about
do it so you're starting to get the
sense right whichever variable X or Y
you slap the constant or variable
whatever on that's what you're going to
modify so that's why this is a
horizontal flip and this this would be a
okay so you got to be careful
it does it does make a difference okay
so the sine of s is an odd function
thing right so yes you can so in this
case a horizontal and a vertical flip
are the same oh yeah right right yeah
they're the same so but obviously the
place that would not be the case okay
tan inverse since it's also an odd
function I found a coin horizontal into
the surface
okay so let's just quickly do some
examples let's just drill site averse
first I can't just stand it old saying
goes
there we go okay now like I said having
devoted a whole bunch of time to this
but you guys know by now you're gonna
have to put points on this to state you
know you know beginning and end up
domain and the beginning and end of your
range of course let's do that
now if that's what regular old side of
us looks like okay let's start to change
it a little bit we will start to go
through some of these and what's the
best way it's actually number one
workout you graph at number two which is
just as common work out what the domain
and range are okay so for instance if
what I know our studio is y equals two
sine inverse of X okay now there's a
couple of different ways to think about
this right you can't think about it as
oh it should be twice as high rank
you're stretching it out that kind of
thing I think the most methodical way to
do it is to make sure whatever wherever
the constant is it should be together
with whatever its modifier is right so
this two is not really modifying this
it's actually changing the Y right the
two applies to the Y so that's why it's
a vertical thing okay in the same way I
mean it's kind of obvious because it
can't go anywhere else this three is
modifying the X okay now it's crucial to
get it into this kind of form because
now I can write out my domain and range
okay now coming back to the original
right you're fully away from the new
addition to that the domain here is
minus 1 to 1 and my range is minus plan
- to plan - okay so now that I have not
Y but Y M 2 and not X but X on three I'm
going to put each of these wherever the
corresponding X's and Y's were right so
for example if I'm working out domain
instead of writing X is from minus 1 to
1
I should write x over 3 it's from minus
1 to 1 okay so now if I want to work out
the actual domain which is 4x I multiply
through by 3 so 3 ok now often see this
is the the area that people make and I
used to do it myself is you start from
the the domain you used to you like
minus 1 to 1 and then you're like oh but
I have an X
three and not an X so you're like okay
I'll survive through and then you wonder
why I kind of know which one is it okay
so if you want to make sure you avoid
doing this you see this only applies to
the original graph right now that I
changed the variable okay it's not an X
in there anymore so that's why I might
inform you so avoid that do the same
thing for y so I have a warrior two
sorry
one two in the middle and I'm between
minus planned on to so you can see you
know even if you thought about it before
I came now I'm twice as high right
that's why you're going from minus PI to
PI okay now now that I have all my
domain arranged okay I'm gonna use that
to draw my graph now I think it's
actually really helpful to do this first
right rather than actually start
thinking okay where am I going to put
this because they don't mean that when
you put a scale on there it actually be
you know easier to draw around and
harder to draw okay
now since there's no horizontal or
vertical shift it's going to look
exactly the same as this right it's just
that my labels will be different so I'm
just going to draw the same graph okay
but I'll just label my influence
differently
okay um scale is going to start to get
pretty tricky here okay you know
generally we've said before scales not
that big a deal we're looking mainly for
features okay but with all of these
graphs the features are all going to be
very very similar okay so they are gonna
pay attention to scale now I'm gonna do
a arm I'll do a horizontal shift in a
minute and I'll do a horizontal and a
vertical shift in a second and the
important things are you know you've got
actually have these points this should
be symmetrical around there right and
this um this point inflection should be
directly in the middle and I should be
able to look at that corner and say I
mean in this case it's easy cuz at the
origin okay and so is this but if it's
not at the origin the point of
inflection should be at the right spot
okay there you don't be calculus for
that you see if you know it should be
halfway okay but if it's off if your
point inflection is like somewhere up
here or somewhere down there rather than
bang in the middle don't get you for
that okay because it's can you draw it I
can spit on one let's keep that one
okay now you might have noticed I was
about to start drawing a set of axes and
then I stopped myself which you should
do too
I wish you'd go through this process of
working at domain and range first
because then you work out which parts of
your axis you will actually need okay so
domain is all about this planet here so
this is X on four plus one and that's
between minus 1 and 1
ok so what's the most natural thing to
do first I guess we would subtract 1
from all of them so this is gonna become
minus 2 this is going to become it's on
4 and that's see you right ok now I
multiply 3 by 4 ok so you can see I'm
only gonna need the left hand side of
the accident welcome need the positive
side ok range you can tell me right away
what's the range it's just it's just the
regular one right because as I've
written it there's no modification on Y
ok so it's just what it would be without
any changes okay so now let's draw a set
of axes which as you noticed before it's
just going to be on the left hand side
okay now because I'm going from 0 to
minus 8 right 0 minus a what I do want
to know he is if that's what - 8 years I
need to know n minus 4 is right because
that's where the flava flexion will be
ok and if it's not there if I miss as
I'm drawing it that's a significant
feature - prior to employment that's
fine so I can put those in your interest
to make sure it's it's tall enough and
things are sort of I mean the closer it
is to being square and easier used to
make sure that number one you get to a
vertical line up here and number two you
come through and you can you can have in
my shape there ok if it's really Squatch
this way or that way
it's hard to make the features an
obvious okay
there you go